hey guys it's Justine I'm Jenna we are
so excited because right now we are in
Montana to announce something we are
working on that is so exciting actually
been working on this for a year now we
partnered with Sony to have our very own
camera okay cool that'll cut took like a
nice montage
[Music]
sorry Montana and last year we went to
svet it was Sony called condo and we had
the absolute best time ever
I left that event with friends I was
inspired we learned so much about camera
gear that we didn't even know I mean
sometimes finding friends and
inspiration actually the hardest part in
life so the fact that that happened we
were very motivated to have something
very similar but for video creators we
kept calling it camera camp it had that
camp vibe because everyone was like so
close and we were doing activities so we
had such a good time and Dunn and I were
like we need to do an actual camera camp
so guess what welcome to
[Applause]
headed twist in turns and the Sun beats
down and burns but I keep keep on
pushing September 22nd here in Montana
wait you didn't tell them the best part
that they can come to obviously we wish
that we could have everyone come to this
camp but we do have an application
process and we'll be choosing a hundred
people from those applications that can
come it's gonna be incredible so there's
gonna be a workshop on September 22nd
like Justine said there's gonna be
classes there's gonna be activities
there's gonna be a welcome back there's
gonna be a massive video scavenger hunt
but I highly would suggest if you're
able to to come from maybe the weekend
go visit Glacier National Park
absolutely beautiful so travel and
lodging is not included but all the
meals here are gonna be included all the
activities and the classes and
everything and it really could not be
more excited that you guys can come
along that was the whole reason that we
really wanted to do this because we
wanted other creators and smaller
creators who might not ever get a chance
to go to events like this to have
something where they leave inspired or
meet other creators there's also dogs
here oh my gosh
we've spent half the time petting the
dogs because we're easily distracted
there are so many fun activities and
we'll be giving you guys more
information as the dates get closer most
important part though is if you are
interested in coming it is September
22nd you have to be 18 and older all of
the info is in the description below and
we look forward to all of your
applications because we're gonna be
going through all of them yeah come to
hang out there's also gonna be a lot of
other youtubers and content creators
here and we do plan on doing this again
so if you don't get accepted for the
first round just know that we wish that
we could accept everyone so once this is
a success we'll see you guys in the
future maybe we should stop talking and
go show them camera cameras we need to
show you Montana
[Music]
there's an elk there's two actually I'm
trying to get the shot here with this
camera the zoom lens and also vlog at
the same time
means
[Music]
yeah
well camera camp half horse riding yes
this is Chester a zero of Chester's
friend
[Music]
I'll see you soon okay we'll see you in
September bye baby
goodbye sweetie